we're learning that the gunmen who went
on a shooting rampage in West Texas
called police before and during the
massacre
Mireya Villarreal reports on what
investigators are saying he was on a
long spiral of going down he didn't wake
up Saturday morning and walk into his
company and then it happened
authorities say both 36 year old Seth
Aaron aider and his employer at an oil
services company called police after
ATAR was fired Saturday morning potater
was gone by the time they arrived was it
hard to keep up with him and how quickly
he was moving absolutely it was FBI
Special Agent Christopher combs says
during aiders shooting rampage across
Midland County and Odessa
Eider was also calling 911 he was the
guy doing it there were over 15
different crime scenes stretching over a
10 mile radius
on average combs says most active
shooting incidents are over in about six
minutes but this incident lasted well
over an hour
FBI agents raiding aiders properties say
it was strange and reflective of his
mental state what is it about this
particular man that is unique and
different about other active shooting
situations besides just that he was
mobile you look at the ones we've
already had this week this year it's
very similar in nature and what we have
and what are those characteristics I
think the most important characteristics
where people can help us is this
spiraling downward path that these
individuals have Bria thank you